It was 2004 and Annie Duke was about to win $2 million. I'm all in. And with that top-air Phil Helmuth going all in with his 450,000 chips, Annie Duke put the pressure on Phil when she checked raised him. This was the final hand of the World Series of Poker tournament of champions. They had these incredible Hall of Fame players like Dora Branson, who was a Hall of Famer, Johnny Chan, who was a Hall of Poker tournament of champions. They had these incredible Hall of Fame players, like Doyle Branson, who was a Hall of Famer, Johnny Chan, who was a Hall of Famer, and then Phil Helmuth,
那是2004年，安妮·杜克（Annie Duke）即将赢得200万美元。“我全下了。”随着菲尔·赫尔穆特（Phil Helmuth）顶对全下他那45万筹码，安妮·杜克过牌加注，给菲尔施加了压力。这是世界扑克大赛冠军赛的最后一手牌。场上有这些不可思议的名人堂玩家，比如身为名人堂成员的多拉·布拉森（Dora Branson）、约翰尼·陈（Johnny Chan），还有菲尔·赫尔穆特，
who has the most championships of anyone in the history of the World Series of Poker. And then there was me. And he calls the all in. And Phil sees what he's up against. Annie and this guy Phil were the last two at the table. And Annie has overcome with emotion, seeing how close she is to winning this championship.
他是世界扑克大赛历史上获得冠军最多的人。然后是我。他跟注了全下。菲尔看到了他的对手是谁。安妮和这个叫菲尔的家伙是桌上仅剩的两个人。安妮被情绪淹没了，看到自己离赢得这个冠军是如此之近。
Annie's crying, Phil's standing up, pissing back and forth, the dealers laying out the cards, that will determine who wins. Annie has control of his hand. Now here comes the turn. It's a seven, no help for Phil. Annie was the only woman in this competition. She had knocked out eight guys, eight of the best players
安妮在哭，菲尔站着，来回踱步，发牌员摆出将决定谁是赢家的牌。安妮掌控着这手牌。现在转牌来了。是一张7，对菲尔毫无帮助。安妮是这场比赛中唯一的女性。她淘汰了八个男人，八个世界上最顶尖的玩家
in the world to get to this point. Annie Duke is now one car to away from $2 million. But I didn't really feel like I deserved to be at that table. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Today, we're going to take the whole podcast to tell you the story about being an outsider. It's why Annie Duke didn't feel she deserved to be at that table,
才走到了这一步。安妮·杜克现在距离200万美元只有一张牌的距离。但其实我并不觉得自己配得上坐在那张桌子上。这里是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是香卡·维丹坦（Shankar Vantam）。今天，我们将用整期播客来给你讲讲关于作为一个局外人的故事。这就是为什么安妮·杜克觉得自己不配坐在那张桌子上，
and it's a perfect illustration of a very powerful idea and psychology called stereotype threat. It's an insidious thing, here's how it works. Let's say that you think people have a certain stereotype about you. There's a part of you that's afraid that your actions and behavior will prove the stereotype true. I'm sort of thinking about, well if I fold and I'm wrong everybody's gonna be like see she plays like a girl like look how he pushed her around. But Annie's story is also about a second idea and this idea often has a positive outcome. This idea is called stereotype tax. That's when a stereotype that others have about you
这也是对心理学中一个非常强大的概念——刻板印象威胁（stereotype threat）的完美阐释。这是一件潜移默化的事，它是这样运作的。假设你认为别人对你有某种刻板印象。你内心深处会有一部分害怕你的行动和行为会证实那个刻板印象是真的。我当时在想，如果我弃牌而我猜错了，每个人都会觉得“看吧，她打起牌来就像个娘们儿，你看他是怎么摆布她的”。但安妮的故事也关乎第二个概念，而这个概念通常会产生积极的结果。这个概念被称为“刻板印象税”（stereotype tax）。当别人对你的刻板印象
works to your advantage. If somebody was at the table who was so emotionally invested in the fact that I was a woman given that they're treating me that way, how can I come up with the best strategy to take their money? Because I guess in the end isn't that the best revenge. Annie had started playing poker in 1994. And by the time she got to that championship game 10 years later, she had basically figured out how to make stereotypes about women and poker work for her. So I can tell you that the first year that I played in the World Series of Poker main event,
对你有利时，这就是刻板印象税。如果桌上有人对我是个女性这件事有着如此强烈的情感执念，既然他们这样对待我，我该如何想出最佳策略来赢走他们的钱？因为我想归根结底，这不就是最好的复仇吗？安妮于1994年开始打扑克。到了10年后她进入那场冠军赛时，她基本上已经摸清了如何让人们对女性和扑克的刻板印象为她所用。所以我可以告诉你，我参加世界扑克大赛主赛事的头一年，
which was in 1994. 3% of the entrance were women, and last year that number would have been the same. Wow, so this is an extraordinarily male-dominated sport. Completely. I was generally the only woman at the table. I had to really love that game in order to be willing to expose myself to a lot of the behavior that I was experiencing.
也就是1994年，3%的参赛者是女性，去年这个数字也差不多。哇，所以这是一项男性统治色彩极其浓厚的运动。完全是的。我通常是桌上唯一的女性。我必须真正热爱这项游戏，才愿意让自己暴露在我所经历的那些行为之中。
Tell me what you heard. What did people say? There were people who were incredibly welcoming. There were other people. There was one guy who I lost a pot to and he said, don't cry. I'll give you your money back if we go across the street to the northern. The northern was a hotel. Wow.
告诉我你听到了什么。人们都说了些什么？有些人极其热情。还有些人。有个家伙我输给他一局，他说：“别哭，如果你跟我和街对面的北方酒店（the northern）去开房，我就把钱还给你。”北方酒店是一家酒店。哇。
You know, and I got called a lot of bad things, but to think about it as, okay, given that this person is viewing me in a way that I find disrespectful, try to separate yourself from your emotional reaction to that and think about how you can use that to your advantage. Annie had learned to make her opponents pay literally for the stereotypes they held about women. Right. At the poker table, for example, I sort of in my head divided people into three categories. One was the flirting showvonist and that person was really viewing me in a way that was sexual. And not as overtly as the guy who invited her back to the great Northern Hotel. These were just guys who sometimes seem more concerned about getting Annie to like them
你知道的，我挨了很多难听的话，但如果换个角度想，好吧，既然这个人对我的看法是我觉得不尊重的，那就试着将你自己从对那种行为的情感反应中剥离出来，想想你该如何利用这一点为自己所用。安妮已经学会了让她的对手为他们对女性的刻板印象付出代价，字面意义上的代价。没错。比方说，在扑克桌上，我大致把人分为三类。第一类是调情沙文主义者，那个人看待我的方式带有某种色情意味。这不像那个邀请她回伟大北方酒店的家伙那么露骨。这些家伙有时似乎更关心如何让安妮喜欢他们，
than they were about winning. Like they'd show me their whole cards when they were done with the hand to show me whether it was a good fold or not. They'd kind of tell me during the hand if I was alone with them in the hand, you know, what they had. They were trying to make nice with you. They were trying to make nice with me. Exactly.
而不是赢得比赛。比如他们打完一手牌后会把底牌亮给我看，让我知道这算不算是一个好的弃牌。如果这手牌只有我和他两个人，他们会在牌局进行中告诉我他们拿的是什么牌。他们试图对你示好。他们试图对我和善。没错。
I never did go out on a date with any of them, but it was kind of flirtatious at the table and I could use that to my advantage. Then there's a second kind of guy. What I would call the disrespecting show of this, who mainly just thought that women weren't creative. That they could only think one level deep. So they didn't believe that you knew how to bluff, for example, because that's a level deep in your thinking. They didn't
我从来没有和他们中的任何一个人约会过，但桌上的气氛确实有点调情意味，我可以利用这一点来为自己谋利。然后是第二类人。我称之为不尊重人的沙文主义者，他们主要认为女性缺乏创造力，思维只能达到第一层。所以他们不相信你知道如何诈唬（bluff），因为那需要更深一层的思维。他们不
think that you really had creativity. They thought you were very straightforward in the way that you play, because you know you're a girl. Right, so they assume that you're naive, basically. Exactly. So there are strategies that you can use against them. Mainly you can bluff those people a lot. And then there's a third kind of guy. Perhaps the most reckless. The angry show of anist. This is a guy who would do anything to avoid being beaten by a woman. You couldn't bluff them because they would call you all the time for fear that you might be bluffing them. And then they would also try to push you around a lot. So they would play extremely aggressively against you.
认为你真的有创造力。他们认为你的打法非常直白，因为你知道你是个女孩。没错，所以他们基本上假设你很天真。没错。所以你可以针对他们使用一些策略。主要是你可以经常诈唬这些人。然后是第三类人。也许是最鲁莽的一类。愤怒的沙文主义者。这种人会为了避免被女人击败而做出任何事。你没法诈唬他们，因为他们会一直跟注你，生怕你是在诈唬他们。而且他们还会试图对你大肆施压。所以他们会对你采取极其激进的打法。
They'd be trying to bluff you all the time. Because the best thing that could happen to them was that they bluffed you. And then they could show you that they had a terrible hand and be like, ha ha, little girl, look what happened to you. Right. Because that would confirm that everything that they believed about you was true. Right. So you can just sort of wait until they, what I say is, until they would impale themselves
他们会一直试图诈唬你。因为对他们来说最好的情况就是他们诈唬了你。然后他们就能向你展示他们拿到了一手烂牌，并说道：“哈哈，小丫头，瞧瞧你落得什么下场。”没错。因为那会证实他们对你的一切成见都是真的。没错。所以你只需静静地等待，直到他们——我称之为——直到他们自投罗网，
on your chips. I have to ask you, though, so it's clear that thinking about this mathematically and in a very detached and unemotional way gave you an edge at the poker table and I can clearly see how that's very smart. But you're not a robot, you're not a computer. At some level you also are processing how people actually are behaving toward you. And I'm wondering if you could talk a minute about how this felt. Most of the time I would compartmentalize while I was at the table, I would sort of say
撞上你的筹码。不过我得问你，显然，用数学的、非常客观且抽离情感的方式来思考，确实让你的扑克牌桌上占据了优势，我完全能看出这有多聪明。但你不是机器人，你不是计算机。在某种程度上，你也在处理人们实际对待你的方式。我想知道你能不能谈谈这种感觉是怎样的。大多数时候，我在桌上时会进行心理隔离，我会对自己说：
I have emotions about this, I'm going to set them aside and deal with them later. And then I would leave the table and drive home in tears. Coming up, feeling like an imposter. It was always in the back of my mind, like, do they really respect me? Why are they talking to me? Is it just because I'm a girl or do they actually respect my play? More from Annie Duke, after this. Annie Duke after this. Welcome back to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vidantam. We're talking with Poker Champion Annie Duke about stereotypes, how they affected her,
我对这些事情有情绪，我要把它们放在一边，以后再处理。然后我会离开牌桌，一路哭着开车回家。接下来，感觉自己像个冒牌货。这总是在我的脑海深处盘旋：“他们真的尊重我吗？他们为什么跟我说话？仅仅因为我是个女孩，还是他们真的尊重我的牌技？”更多安妮·杜克的访谈，广告后继续。安妮·杜克的访谈，广告后继续。欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹坦。我们正在与扑克冠军安妮·杜克探讨刻板印象、它们对她的影响，
and how she learned to turn them to her own advantage. In her first 10 years of the Poker Table, Annie was able to compartmentalize her emotions, and she won a lot of money doing this using stereotype tax to her advantage. That was until 2004 at the Tournament of Champions. Intimidation is such a big part of being a successful player. Is that going to come into play at this table, you think? Oh, not really. In fact, these players know each other so well.
以及她是如何学会将其转化为自己的优势的。在扑克桌上的前十年，安妮能够将自己的情感进行心理隔离，她靠着利用刻板印象税赢了许多钱。直到2004年的冠军赛。恐吓是成为一个成功玩家的重要部分。你认为这会在牌桌上发挥作用吗？哦，其实不会。事实上，这些玩家彼此太熟悉了。
If one of them sneezes, somebody else has already handed them a handkerchief. Actually, at least for Annie, that wasn't true. She had never played poker on TV before, and she was pretty sure she had been invited as the token woman, that she was way out of her league. She thought that ESPN, televising the game in this way for the first time, just thought it was good optics
如果其中一个人打喷嚏，另一个人早就递上手帕了。其实，至少对安妮来说，事实并非如此。她以前从未在电视上打过扑克，她很确凿地认为自己被邀请只是为了凑数的女性象征，她觉得自己完全不在一个水平线上。她认为ESPN首次以这种方式转播比赛，只是觉得让她在场上
to have her there. And I went in there with this incredible fear that my play, which was now in front of lipstick cameras, so my mistakes were no longer going to be private to me, that that was going to expose that everybody was right and I was actually a terrible player and despite the fact that I had spent the last 10 years making my living playing poker at the highest levels of the game, that I didn't really deserve to have ever won anything I was bad and I had just gotten lucky and now everybody was going to know it and what they were saying was true. You felt like an imposter.
观感很好。我是带着一种难以置信的恐惧走进那里的，我的牌技现在暴露在口红摄像头（lipstick cameras）前，所以我的错误不再属于我个人私密，这会暴露所有人都认为我是对的，我其实是个糟糕的玩家；尽管事实上我已经过去10年靠在游戏最高水平打扑克维生，但我根本不配赢得过任何东西，我很烂，我只是运气好，现在所有人都知道了，他们说的是真的。你觉得自己是个冒牌货。
Completely. You were facing a very difficult situation here which is you're not just juggling with what's happening at the poker table, but you're juggling with all this other psychological crap in a way that just makes it hard to focus on what it is that you're actually doing. And in so many ways, that not to me is a perfect illustration of stereotype threat. It shows that when there's a stereotype that's in the air, when there's a stereotype that multiple people believe, even if you don't believe it yourself, if you're the person who is potentially at the receiving end of that stereotype, it affects your behavior
完全是这样。你当时面对着一个非常困难的状况，那就是你不仅要应付扑克桌上发生的事情，还要应付所有其他乱七八糟的心理负担，这让你很难专注于你实际在做的事情。在很多方面，对我来说，这简直是刻板印象威胁的完美诠释。它表明，当空气中弥漫着一种刻板印象时，当多人相信某种刻板印象时，即使你自己并不相信，如果你是那个可能成为该刻板印象接收端的人，它也会影响你的行为，
in such a way that you become more likely to make the stereotype come true. I think that that's completely true. It was always in the back of my mind, like, that do they really respect me? Why are they talking to me? Is it just because they are thinking about me in a different way? Like, they want to be friends with me because I'm a girl, or do they actually respect my play? There was a particular hand, Annie says,
让你更有可能让这种刻板印象成真。我认为这完全正确。它总是盘旋在我的脑海深处：“他们真的尊重我吗？他们为什么跟我说话？难道仅仅是因为他们对我有不同的看法？比如，他们想跟我做朋友因为我是个女孩，还是他们真的尊重我的牌技？”安妮说，有一手特定的牌，
when stereotype threat got the better of her. So, in this particular hand where I had two tens... This was early in the game. There were nine people still at the table. And for Annie. Certainly in the beginning of that tournament, I just kept thinking to myself like, oh please don't let me be the first one out, because then everybody will be right. Because of course, she wasn't good enough, she didn't belong at the table, she couldn't
当时刻板印象威胁彻底击垮了她。所以，在这一手我拿着一对10的牌中……这是比赛早期。桌上还有九个人。对于安妮来说。至少在该锦标赛的开始阶段，我一直对自己说：“哦，拜托，千万别让我第一个出局，因为那样所有人就都对啦。”因为当然了，她不够优秀，她不属于这张牌桌，她根本
hang with the guys. That discourse was kind of running in the back of my head the whole time. And then Annie winds up in a head-to-head match-up with one other player. Her hand was a pair of tens, which is a pretty good hand. It was good enough that there wasn't a huge chance that her opponent, this guy Greg Raymer, had a better hand, but there was still a chance. As a professional poker player, this is the kind of hand that you evaluate in a matter of seconds.
无法与这群男人抗衡。这种论调一直盘旋在我的脑海深处。接着安妮与另一个玩家展开了单挑。她的牌是一对10，这是一手相当不错的牌。好到她的对手——这个叫格雷格·雷默（Greg Raymer）的家伙——拿到更好牌的几率并不是非常大，但依然有这种可能。作为一名职业扑克手，这就是那种你能在几秒钟内评估出来的牌。
So I really needed to eliminate that hand as a possibility, and I was having a lot of trouble doing that, because I was so afraid of making this really bad big decision on television, and having everyone say I told you so. This was a pivotal hand, but a lot of the significance was really just in Annie's head. If she folded, but really lot of the significance was really just in Annie's head. If she folded, but really had the best hand, everybody's gonna be like, see, she plays like a girl, like look how he pushed her around. And if I called and I was wrong, then I could come up with a whole other thing, like look how bad she is, didn't she know that he had the best hand, like any idiot would have known that, you know. And that was running in my head as I was
所以我真的需要排除那种可能性，而我很难做到这一点，因为我太害怕在电视上做出这种非常糟糕的重大决定了，然后让每个人都说“我早就告诉过你了”。这是一手关键牌，但其中的很大一部分重要性其实只是存在于安妮的脑海里。如果她弃牌了，但实际上拿的是最好的牌，每个人都会觉得“看吧，她打起牌来就像个娘们儿，你看他是怎么摆布她的”。如果我跟注了而我猜错了，那我就会招致另一番评价，比如“瞧她有多烂，难道她不知道对方拿着最好的牌吗，任何白痴都该知道的”，诸如此类。当我试图做出这个决定时，这些话一直在我的脑海里翻滚。
trying to make this decision. So you're down if you do and you're down if you don't? Absolutely, absolutely. And it was incredibly difficult and it wasn't until I kind of snapped to and saw this tell that he had. And we see a tell you mean what? So a tell is a physical, well, it could be something verbal that somebody says that gives a clue, but generally when we talk about tellers,
所以你是左右为难？绝对的，绝对的。这极其困难，直到我突然回过神来，注意到了他露出的马脚（tell）。当我们说马脚时你指的是什么？所以马脚是一个身体上的，嗯，也可以是别人说出的某些能提供线索的话语，但通常当我们谈论马脚时，
we're talking about something physical that somebody does, that telegraphs the quality of their hand, or at least what they think the quality of their hand is. So Greg Raymer did something which I haven't actually said what he actually did, because I think that's unfair to him. But he did something that gave away the fact that his hand was very, very strong. Which allowed me to then fold, and at that moment I was actually quite confident in it. But Annie's confidence in her decision was short-lived. Another player came up to her during a break in the game, and what he said,
我们指的是某人做出的某种能透露其牌面质量，或者至少透露他们认为自己牌面质量如何的肢体动作。所以格雷格·雷默做了一件事——我其实没有说他具体做了什么，因为我觉得对不太公平。但他做出的某件事泄露了这样一个事实：他的牌非常非常强。这让我得以选择弃牌，而在那一刻我其实相当确信这一点。但安妮对这个决定的信心并未持续多久。在比赛间隙，另一位玩家走到她面前，而他所说的话，
kicked the stereotype threat in Annie's head into overdrive. Phil, help me right after that hand occurred came up and just told me like what an idiot I was because clearly Greg Raymer had Ace King and I thought, oh my gosh, this is a guy who's like at the now I think he's a 12 time world champion, but at the time he probably had you know seven world championships or. And he seemed pretty confident that he had Ace King. And then I had an hour in my room having a panic attack. Well, we were on break from the tournament. It was pretty awful. Annie's stereotype threat had produced what poker players call tilt. Tilt when you allow kind of bad things that happen to you that very often are out of your control to cause you to be a poor decision maker going forward.
让安妮脑海中的刻板印象威胁瞬间加速飙升。菲尔·赫尔穆特在那手牌刚打完后就走过来，直接告诉我我有多白痴，因为很明显格雷格·雷默拿的是A-K。我想：“哦天哪，这家伙可是——现在我觉得他是12次世界冠军了，但当时他大概拿过7次世界冠军吧。”他似乎非常确信自己拿的是A-K。接着我在房间里度过了痛苦的一个小时，恐慌发作了。嗯，当时我们正在比赛中场休息。那感觉相当糟糕。安妮受到的刻板印象威胁引发了扑克手们所说的“上头”（tilt）。当你让那些往往超出你控制的、对你不利的糟糕事情，导致你在接下来的决策中表现糟糕时，这就是上头。
You know, Annie, social science researchers have figured out one way to beat stereotype threat. There was an interesting experiment conducted at Stanford University by Greg Walton and others where he was concerned that black students at Stanford might feel that they were in postures on campus and when negative things happen to them they get a bad grade or a bad interaction with a professor. They'll interpret that in the light of thinking, I don't really belong here. And so he had the students come in and he had them describe negative things that happened to them during their freshman year, but he also had them describe how those negative things were transient events. You get a bad grade or you have a bad interaction,
你知道吗，安妮，社会科学研究人员已经找到了一种战胜刻板印象威胁的方法。斯坦福大学的格雷格·沃尔顿（Greg Walton）等人曾做过一项有趣的实验，他担心斯坦福大学的黑人学生可能会觉得自己是校园里的冒牌货，当负面事情发生时——比如他们得了差评或是跟教授发生了不愉快的互动——他们会把这解读为“我真的不属于这里”。于是他让学生们进来，让他们描述自己在大一期间发生的负面事情，但他也让他们描述这些负面事情是如何只是一场短暂的事件。你得了个低分或者有了一次糟糕的互动，
but two weeks later, that's not a big deal anymore. And he was using this as a way to get students to understand that everyone experiences setbacks. It's only when you see local setbacks as global problems that the risk of stereotype threat comes in and you start to feel like an imposter. Exactly. And it's something that I've used a lot at the table.
但两周后，这就根本不算什么了。他用这种方法让学生们明白，每个人都会经历挫折。只有当你把局部的挫折视为全局性的问题时，刻板印象威胁的风险才会介入，你才会开始觉得自己像个冒牌货。完全正确。这也是我在牌桌上经常使用的方法。
When I lose a big pot and it feels like the end of the world, I try to think about how will that really affect my bottom line in the long run. So an example would be, you get a flat tire. You're standing by the side of the road. It feels like the worst thing that's ever happened to you. And then if you stop for a second and you say to yourself, well, if it's a year from now, well, that flat tire
当我输掉一大盘筹码，感觉就像世界末日时，我会试着去想，从长远来看，这究竟会如何影响我的最终收益。举个例子，比如你车胎爆了。你站在路边。感觉这是你经历过的最糟糕的事情。然后如果你停下来一秒钟，对自己说，好吧，如果是一年以后，那个爆胎
have affected my happiness for the year in any way. And the answer to that, of course, is no. It wouldn't tick it up or down. So in that same sense, when you have something really bad happen to stop for a second and think about, well, I've had stuff like this happen to me before, when it was a few weeks later, did it really affect my overall level of happiness and the answers generally know.
会以任何方式影响我这一年的幸福感吗？答案当然是不会。它不会让幸福感增加或减少。所以在同样的意义上，当遇到非常糟糕的事情时，停下来一秒钟想一想，好吧，以前我也经历过类似的事情，几周后，它真的影响了我整体的幸福感水平吗？答案通常是不会。
In just a moment, the conclusion of the poker championship. Annie Duke is now one card away from $2 million. You won't want to miss this. Phil Helm you'll see that eight to win this pot. Both players on their feet. We'd like to say a quick thank you to one of our sponsors, stamps.com. Stamps.com helps businesses avoid time consuming trips to the post office.
稍后为您带来扑克锦标赛的尾声。安妮·杜克距离200万美元只剩一张牌的距离。你绝对不想错过这个。菲尔·赫尔穆特需要一张8来赢得这个底牌。两位玩家都站了起来。我们要向我们的赞助商之一stamps.com表达简短的谢意。Stamps.com帮助企业避免前往邮局耗费时间的行程。
Use your own computer and printer to print official US postage for any letter or package. Then the mailman picks it up. No more wasting time going to the post office or wasting money on expensive postage meters. Right now, sign up for stamps.com and use the promo code Brain for a special offer, a four week trial, plus postage, and a digital scale. Go to stamps.com, click on the microphone, and type in Brain. Thanks for listening toIn Brain. every week. That's Pop Culture Happy Hour from NPR. Find it now at npr.org slash podcast and on the NPR-1 app.
使用您自己的电脑和打印机为任何信件或包裹打印官方美国邮资。然后邮递员会来取走它。再也不用浪费时间去邮局，或者把钱浪费在昂贵的邮资机上了。现在，注册stamps.com并使用优惠码Brain即可享受特别优惠：四周试用期、外加邮资以及一个数字秤。访问stamps.com，点击麦克风图标，并输入Brain。感谢收听《隐藏的大脑》。每周收听。那是来自NPR的《流行文化欢乐时光》（Pop Culture Happy Hour）。现在可以在npr.org/podcast以及NPR-1应用程序上找到它。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. I'm talking with Annie Duke about the final hands in the world's biggest poker champion. So after she nearly lost it in her hotel room, Annie comes back to the table and she has a stroke of luck. She wins a pretty nice hand. And the river card, it's a six of spades, no help for Greg Ramer. He loses that hand. Annie Duke lives to tell the tale yet again, doubles her mind. And you can actually hear at this point in the game, Annie begins to loosen up. It's a sign that she's finally gotten the stereotype threat
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹坦。我正在和安妮·杜克探讨世界最大扑克赛的最后几手牌。因此，在酒店房间里差点崩溃之后，安妮回到了牌桌上，她迎来了一点好运。她赢了一手相当不错的牌。河牌是一张黑桃6，对格雷格·雷默毫无帮助。他输掉了那手牌。安妮·杜克再次死里逃生，筹码翻倍。你其实可以听到，此时在比赛中，安妮开始放松下来。这是一个标志，说明她终于
under control. The flop was just wow. Yeah. It doesn't matter what order they come in, right? It doesn't matter. Well, it kind of does in that situation. Annie had turned on the charm with Greg Raymer. And the next time they face each other in a hand,
控制住了刻板印象威胁。翻牌圈简直是绝了。是的。它们按什么顺序出现并不重要，对吧？不重要。嗯，在这种情况下其实还是有点关系的。安妮对格雷格·雷默使出了魅力攻势。而在下一手他们正面交锋的牌中，
Raymer got cocky. Now Raymer needs to call or get out of the way. I don't know what he's thinking about here. It's one thing when he called with 9-8 suited before, when he's chip leader and is a small cost. But he has a lot fewer chips and not as good of a hand. I call. Well, the world champion is gonna call. Just to be clear, this was not the right thing to do.
雷默变得傲慢起来。现在雷默需要跟注或者退缩。我不知道他在这里琢磨什么。这和之前他用同花9-8跟注时完全不同，当时他是筹码领先者，成本很低。但他现在筹码少得多，牌也没有那么好。我跟注。好吧，世界冠军要跟注了。需要说明的是，这并不是正确的做法。
Raymer had a pretty weak hand. And now the river card, it's a three no good for Raymer. Well, calling that all in with the 98 off suit line, that's a meltdown of sorts for Greg Raymer. On the next hand, Annie would knock out Raymer, whose nickname was Fossilman. It is an ace, it's no help to Fossilman and he goes down. Just like that, Annie was back in the zone. And that actually sort of brought me out of this very bad head space. Soon the table dwindled to four players. Then there were three. It's a three and that's the end of the line for Howard Letterman. Until finally, Annie and Phil Helmuth, the guy who nearly destroyed her confidence earlier in the game, these are the only two left.
雷默的牌相当弱。接着是河牌，一张3，对雷默毫无用处。好吧，用杂色9-8跟注全下，对格雷格·雷默来说算是一种彻底的崩溃。在下一手牌中，安妮将淘汰雷默，他的绰号叫“化石人”（Fossilman）。是一张A，对化石人毫无帮助，他出局了。就这样，安妮重新找到了状态。这其实把从那种非常糟糕的心态中拉了回来。很快，桌上的人数减少到四个人。然后剩下三个。是一张3，霍华德·莱特曼（Howard Letterman）的征程到此结束。直到最后，安妮和菲尔·赫尔穆特——那个在比赛早些时候差点摧毁她信心的人——场上只剩下他们两个。
And Annie says to him, You could argue that this little old me-at Somehow. Really did a number on Phil Helmuth. Somehow. Because for the next half a dozen hands, he just did not know what to make of Annie. Well, Annie Duke will shy away from this hand. God dang it all, I should have moved in before the flop.
安妮对他说：你可以说这个小小的我——不知怎么的。真的把菲尔·赫尔穆特给难倒了。不知怎么的。因为在接下来的半打牌中，他完全不知道该拿安妮怎么办。好吧，安妮·杜克要在这手牌前退缩了。见鬼的，我应该在翻牌前就全下的。
Annie keeps the charm turned up. Are you saying you had a good hand, Phil? I had a pocket pair. Sorry, I couldn't accommodate you. You gave me the race. Yeah, I just... And they go back and forth like this all the way to the final hand. Annie's got Phil second guessing every movie makes and every movie doesn't make.
安妮继续保持着魅力攻势。你是说你有一手好牌，菲尔？我有一对口袋对子。抱歉，我没能配合你。你给了我加注的机会。对，我只是……他们就这样你来我往，一直持续到最后一手牌。安妮让菲尔对他的每一个动作和每一个不作出的动作都充满了猜测。
Phil Helmuth was holding a 10-8. Phil ready to act with 45. High pair and he will bet 45,000. But Annie's hand was much better, a King 10. I raised. Annie Duke is gonna raise Phil Helmuth. And she's gonna raise 200,000 as she has set her trap. Phil thought Annie was bluffing. In fact, he thought that she'd been bluffing a lot.
菲尔·赫尔穆特手里拿着10-8。菲尔准备用4.5万筹码采取行动。高对，他将下注4.5万。但安妮的牌要好得多，是一张K-10。我加注。安妮·杜克要加注菲尔·赫尔穆特了。她要加注20万，因为她已经布下了陷阱。菲尔以为安妮在诈唬。事实上，他认为她之前一直在诈唬。
I'm all in. And with that top pair, Phil Helmuth going all in with his 450,000 chips Annie Duke put the pressure on Phil and she checkraised him and now with Phil's all in call the pressure is back on Annie. About 450 more. She set the trap but Phil has come back very strong. At this point it's obvious to both Annie and Phil the other person has a strong hand.
我全下了。随着顶对出现，菲尔·赫尔穆特用他45万的筹码全下了，安妮·杜克给菲尔施加了压力，她过牌加注了他，现在随着菲尔的全下跟注，压力又回到了安妮身上。大约还要450多万。她布下了陷阱，但菲尔的反击非常强劲。此时，安妮和菲尔都心知肚明，对方都有一手好牌。
The question is how strong? person has a strong hand. The question is, how strong? That's a judgement call. It's based on probability, instinct, and all the undercurrents, expectations, and stereotypes that have been running through the game the entire time. But now there's only one question. If Annie thinks that Phil has misjudged her, she knows she should call his bet. I call. Any calls he all in?
问题是，有多强？人有一手好牌。问题是，有多强？这是一个判断题。它基于概率、直觉，以及贯穿整场比赛的所有暗流、期望和刻板印象。但现在只有一个问题。如果安妮认为菲尔对她产生了误判，她知道自己应该跟注他的下注。我跟注。安妮跟注了他的全下？
And Phil sees what he's up against. What he's up against, you're meaning, the dealer's cards. That's going to determine who wins. And if there was any moment that perfectly revealed how much of an outsider Annie was in this situation, it's this next one. Annie Duke is now one card away from $2 million. I mean, eight, please.
菲尔看到了他的对手是谁。他所面临的对手，你是说，发牌员的牌。那将决定谁是赢家。如果说有哪个瞬间能完美展现安妮在这种情况下是多么像一个局外人，那就是接下来的这一刻。安妮·杜克现在距离200万美元只有一张牌的距离。我是说，来张8，拜托。
Phil Helmuth needs an eight to win this pot. Both players on their feet anticipating the river card. It's a three. Annie Duke has defeated nine of the strongest poker players in the world. And when's the first ever World Series of Poker tournament of champion? She won every f*** and race for two f***s. In classic reality television style,
菲尔·赫尔穆特需要一张8来赢得这个底牌。两位玩家都站起身来，期待着河牌。是一张3。安妮·杜克击败了世界上最强大的九位扑克玩家。并赢得了史上第一届世界扑克大赛冠军赛！她赢得每一场该死的比赛，两场该死的……以经典的真人秀节目风格，
cameras fall of fail as he storms away from the table, out of door just pacing around talking to himself. She f***ed. Check, raised me six times. I know she didn't have it all six times. Oh my god, I won! It was the reaction of a man who just got beat. She had to be 30 to 1 to win this. By some one, I love Annie, who wasn't supposed to win. But f**k. And maybe wasn't even supposed to be at the table in the first place.
摄像机跟着菲尔拍，他气冲冲地离开牌桌，走到门外来回踱步，自言自语。她他妈的。过牌加注了我六次。我知道她不可能每次都有。哦天哪，我赢了！这是一个刚被击败的男人的反应。她赢得比赛的赔率可是30比1。有那么一个人，我爱安妮，她本不该赢得比赛。但是他妈的。也许她一开始根本就不配坐在那张桌子上。
But precisely because Annie Duke knew how stereotypes can be both threat and advantage. Well, you heard Phil and he was right and he was definitely a long shot to win this all, but as the only female at the table she is now the last man standing. Another f***ing second from my second third, second third. I have to say, Annie, do you, or not just a good poker player, but you're clearly a very wise person? Well, so are you, thank you. Thank you so much for talking with us today, Annie. I really, really appreciate it. Thank you for having me. It was a lot of fun.
但正因为安妮·杜克深知刻板印象既可以是威胁也可以是优势。嗯，你听到了菲尔的话，他说得对，他赢得这一切的希望绝对非常渺茫，但作为桌上唯一的女性，她现在是笑到最后的胜者。又他妈的一秒钟，为了我的第二第三名，第二第三名。我必须说，安妮，你不仅是一个出色的扑克玩家，而且你显然是一个非常睿智的人？嗯，你也是，谢谢。非常感谢你今天和我们交谈，安妮。我真的很感激。谢谢你邀请我。这非常有趣。
I see it, but I don't f***ing believe it. I just don't believe it. For more Hidden Brain, find us on Facebook and Twitter. You can also listen to me on your local public radio station. Hidden Brain is produced by Karam Agargaleson and Maggie Penman. Special thanks this week to Brent Bachman and Jenna Weissberman. I knew I was going to eventually get help you to continue to vent. No money. Alright, let me call my brother.
我看到了，但我他妈就是不信。我就是不信。关于本集的更多内容，请在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们。您也可以在当地的公共广播电台收听我的节目。《隐藏的大脑》由卡拉姆·阿加加莱森（Karam Agargaleson）和玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）制作。本周特别感谢布伦特·巴赫曼（Brent Bachman）和珍娜·韦斯伯曼（Jenna Weissberman）。我知道我最终会得到帮助你继续发泄。没有钱。好吧，让我给我弟弟打电话。
She wants two million. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. I see it, but I don't believe it. I just don't believe it. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她想要两万。我是香卡·维丹坦，这里是NPR。我看到了，但我就是不信。我就是不信。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。